remember toshiba in the 2000s they were
one of the most popular laptop brands in
the world in 2007 they controlled 7.3
percent of the global laptop market
which is more than apple's laptop market
share in 2018 aside from dominating the
laptop space toshiba was a massive
player within the hard drive slash
memory space and consumer electronics
and let's not forget their famous times
square advertisement but over the past
ten years they've fallen off a cliff
their revenues have halved their net
income has stabilized at marginal
numbers they sold off a lot of their
business they were called for accounting
fraud they shut down their laptop
business one of their subs theories
filed for bankruptcy and they have
overall just been struggling to stay
afloat somehow within just 15 years
toshiba went from being a highly
respected japanese electronics company
to mostly being forgotten about so
here's how toshiba got so large in the
first place where they went wrong and
why this may be the end of toshiba
unlike most tech companies today toshiba
wasn't founded within the past few
decades or even the past hundred years
toshiba was actually founded way back on
july 11 1875.
a few years before the company was
founded the japanese ministry of
engineering commissioned an engineer
named tanaka hixaching to develop
telegraphic equipment at the time the
phone was yet to be invented but
telegraphs had been around for nearly 40
years however japan had yet to really
embrace this technology so this
commission was basically a part of the
country's modernization effort anyway
along the development process tanaka
established a company tanaka cesar cruzo
which means tanaka engineering works and
this is what would eventually become
toshiba
initially the company was just selling
telegraph equipment electric switches
and the various communications equipment
after tanaka passed away in 1881 his son
took over the company and sold a part of
the company to general electric this
allowed them to expand into the
production of torpedoes and mines which
was wanted by the japanese navy however
once the navy figured out how to produce
their own weapons they ditched tanaka
engineering which drove the company to
insolvency by 1893 the company ran out
of money and mitsui bank took over the
company and renamed it shibara
engineering works
over the next several years they
developed some utilitarian products such
as a waterwheel powered turbine
generator and a radio transmitter but
none of these really caught steam and
made the company that much money so in
1910 the company formed another deal
with the ge ge agreed to share its
technology with shibara in exchange for
a quarter of the company after this deal
shibara finally started to make some
progress within heavy electrical
machinery but then they got beat down
quite hard in 1923 japan experienced the
great kanto earthquake which claimed the
lives of 100 000 people many of which
were shibara employees and just as
shibara finished reconstruction the
japanese government banned the
production of home appliances in order
to conserve materials for world war ii
to make things worse the us and japan
weren't exactly friends throughout the
war so the partnership with the ge was
iffy to say the least so in 1939 shibara
decided to merge with another g-powered
japanese company called the tokyo genki
and together they formed a tokyo shibara
dengue unlike shibara who focused on
heavy machinery and appliances tokyo
denki was mainly focused on small
consumer electronics throughout the rest
of the war the duo tried to supply the
military with radios vacuum tubes and
the generators but this led to their
factories being constantly bombed
nonetheless these government contracts
left them much better off than most
engineering companies which got
decimated during the war and through the
1940s and 50s these guys picked up all
the devastated engineering companies and
formed a super conglomerate and while
each of these guys were struggling on
their own together they are about to
become an unstoppable force
over the next few decades tokyo shibara
turned up product after product first
they had the tac digital computer in
1954. then there was the transistor tv
and the microwave opened in 1959 and
finally there was the color video phone
the mri system and the laptop throughout
the 70s and 80s aside from launching a
slew of products toshiba also launched a
slew of companies including toshiba
music toshiba chemical toshiba lighting
and technology and toshiba american
information systems when many of these
subsidiaries were formed though the
company wasn't actually called toshiba
it was still called the tokyo shibara
denki and it wasn't until 1994 that they
combined the words tokyo and shibara to
create toshiba and made it the company's
official name it wasn't all smooth
sailing though in 1987 one of toshiba's
upstairs tosiba machine was caught
selling submarine propeller production
equipment to the soviet union and this
was a violation of the kokom agreement
which established an embargo on certain
countries this incident hurt japanese
american relations and resulted in the
prosecution of two senior executives but
despite the setback toshiba continued to
march forward into the new century in
2001 toshiba formed a partnership with
orion electric who was one of the
world's largest oem manufacturers orion
helped toshiba bring tvs and other video
related products to the north american
market this partnership was going well
enough that toshiba actually stopped
in-house crg television production in
2004. shortly after they also shut down
in-house plasma television production
but this partnership didn't last forever
the contract only specified a seven-year
partnership and the two companies went
their separate ways in 2008.
unfortunately this was basically the
peak of toshiba's business but they
didn't know it at the time toshiba was
actually celebrating their success and
they bought the famous times square
display from discover card in 2007. for
the next 11 years toshiba displayed the
countdown every new year but really they
were just counting down to their own
demise
probably one of toshiba's biggest
blunders was investing heavily in
nuclear energy toshiba had a presence
within nuclear energy production since
1970 but their biggest bet didn't come
until 2006. toshiba spent 5.4 billion
dollars to acquire majority stake in the
nuclear power plant company westinghouse
electric at the time this was seen as an
extremely desirable acquisition it was
clear that coal and oil weren't good
long-term energy solutions meanwhile
renewable sources like hydropower and
solar couldn't produce nearly enough
energy so it seemed like safe nuclear
power production was the future toshiba
actually bid three times more than what
analysts thought westinghouse was worth
at the time and after the acquisition
toshiba ceo atsutoshi nishida proudly
announced that nuclear power was going
to grow 50 by 2020 but in reality
nuclear power production hasn't really
grown since 2000. aside from the market
itself not really growing toshiba also
experienced some bad luck in 2011 an
earthquake tsunami disabled the power
supply and cooling of three fukushima
daiichi reactors this led to all three
cores melting within the next few days
and causing a nuclear accident this was
the last thing japan wanted to happen
19500 people had died due to the
earthquake and tsunami and now they had
to evacuate 100 000 people to minimize
radiation as you would guess japan was
done with nuclear energy after this
incident they stopped investments into
the industry and shut down all nuclear
reactors which led to many countries
following suit despite all this toshiba
ceo at the time noriya sasaki assured
investors that nuclear energy would
continue to be a strong option moving
forward but he wouldn't be able to keep
up this raid for much longer one of
westinghouse's biggest customers chicago
bridge and iron company closed the
nuclear division in an effort to keep
the contracts alive westinghouse bought
their nuclear division but it quickly
became clear that these contracts could
not be completed profitably at one point
it became so bad that keeping the
nuclear division open would bank up
toshiba itself so in march of 2017
toshiba let westinghouse file for
bankruptcy and that was basically the
end of toshiba's nuclear business
toshiba may have lost big on their
nuclear bed but they still had their
core electronics business right
well not really you see it toshiba had
spent so much capital and effort in the
nuclear business that they let their
core business slip away from them
throughout the late 2000s and early
2010s we witnessed the mobile revolution
which toshiba completely missed out on
and as for their laptop business
consumers were slowly forgetting about
toshiba here's the thing most people
never bought toshiba laptops because
they love toshiba most people just
bought toshiba laptops because they were
practical affordable and durable in
other words toshiba didn't have much
brand loyalty and the laptop industry
was becoming increasingly unprofitable
survivors like dell and hp completely
altered their strategy they more or less
accepted zero percent margins on their
consumer hardware and focus on trying to
make money through alternative methods
toshiba however didn't get the memo and
they got squeezed as laptop profit
margins trended towards zero they held
on as long as they could but in august
of 2020 they announced that they would
exit the laptop industry after 35 years
in the meantime their television
business wasn't faring too well either
in the early 2010s toshiba had fully
embraced 3d televisions which were super
hot at the time but it didn't take long
for consumers to write it off as a
gimmick and move back to regular tvs
around the same time toshiba also lost
the war against blu-ray toshiba was the
principal supporter of the hd dvd format
but as studios increasingly supported
blu-ray toshiba had no choice but to
give in honestly though given that dvds
themselves were becoming obsolete the
loss of this business was inevitable
even if they had won against blu-ray
with toshiba's laptop business gone and
their tv business on a massive decline
toshiba only had a few things left to
hold on to
today toshiba is no doubt just a shell
of their former self currently they're
staying afloat through two main sectors
which include the memory business and
the industrial equipment business
toshiba was actually the pioneer of
flash memory back in the 1980s but
they've lost significant market share to
samsung over the past decade to make
things even worse toshiba sold their
flash memory unit to save the rest of
their business in 2018. they did get a
solid 18 billion dollars from the sale
but honestly i think they gave up their
last source of hope with this sale after
all the entire company of toshiba itself
is only worth 19 billion dollars today
considering all these hardships i don't
think you'd be too surprised to hear
that toshiba's executives resorted to
faking their numbers
another ceo bowing an apology over
counting problems
this time it's toshiba's hisao tanaka in
the years leading up to 2015 toshiba had
overstated their operating profits by
1.2 billion dollars as you would guess
this was followed up with the ceo
resigning and investor trust being
crushed looking forward it toshiba
doesn't really have much going for them
the majority of their business is just
selling industrial electronics but it
doesn't seem like tochiba is innovating
much there either so it may just be a
matter of time until a competitor
overtakes this industry as well
hopefully toshiba gets their act
together given that they still employ
117 300 people but toshiba can't be
propped up forever just to maintain the
jobs moreover toshiba has already
reduced their workforce by 100 000
people over the past decade so if worse
comes to worst it won't be long until
the remaining 100 000 people are forced
to look for new employment as well
but that's just what i think did you
guys ever have a toshiba laptop comment
that down below
also drop a like if you're glad to hear
that newer more innovative companies are
replacing such laggards and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and continue to subscribe and
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari i'll see you
guys on the next one
you